Hey everyone.
In part one we looked at basic pricing logic for commonly owned substitutes and complements.
In this video we're taking things a step further.
We're going to explore how these concepts apply in real business strategy.
Perhaps we need to retire a substitute or perhaps our complements can actually power our platform pricing.
So let's go ahead and dive into it.
The first thing we want to do is start with substitutes.
Here we are looking at pricing a substitute to avoid cannibalization.
Well, typically that's what we do, but sometimes we may want to cannibalize, that is before somebody else does it for us.
Take Apple for example.
When they launched the iPhone, they effectively killed their own ipod line.
But they did it intentionally because they knew smartphones were going to converge everything that is music and Internet phone and the camera.
So Apple sacrificed the ipod to make room for a much more valuable product.
This is called strategic cannibalization.
The logic here is, are you defending against a competitive threat?
Is the current product near the end of its life cycle?
Can the new substitute command higher margins or generate more loyalty?
If the answer is yes to any of these, then you might want to launch that substitute and go ahead and make that smart long term move.
If you don't cannibalize your own product, someone else will.
Now let's talk about compliments.
Compliments are powerful because you can price one product low or even at a loss and make your own money back on the other good.
Game consoles are a classic example.
Microsoft might lose money on every Xbox they sell, but they make up for it in the high margin.
Video games and subscriptions.
Same Gillette here.
They give away or heavily discount the razor handle.
But the blades, that's where the profit lives.
This strategy works when the complement is consumable or repeat purchases.
The base product creates lock in and the combined usage drops value.
We also see that with bundling.
So Amazon prime for example, includes music, video streaming, free shipping and more.
And they may price each separately.
But if they price them all together, they don't have to sell individual services anymore.
They're now selling a platform.
So in pricing complements, think about product margins.
Think about the ecosystem that you want to create.
Now let's look at a numerical example.
And with this, the cross price elasticity of demand.
So we know that substitutes and complements are going to have different cross price elasticities.
We're going to start with a substitute numerical good.
We have two Colas, Cola A, Cola B, Cola obviously different because one's red and one's blue.
Now, Cola A is the lower margin product.
Cola B is the higher margin product.
We have Cola a selling for $1.
We sell 1,000 of those and our margin is $0.20 per unit sold.
Cola B sells for A$20.
It sells 600 and its margin is $0.50.
So with the old profit or the original profit, what we see is a total profit of $500.
This comes from multiplying the amount sold for Cola A by its margin to get $200 and the amount sold of Cola B by its margin to get $300.
But now what we want to do is implement a new pricing strategy based off of what we know of commonly owned substitutes.
Here our price change is to raise Cola A to $1.15.
This gives us a 15% increase.
Remember, we're raising the price on the lower margin item more because this can help push customers to the higher margin item.
And so Cola B is going to have its price rise to $1.25.
This is only 4.2% increase.
And what we see is our sales are going to adjust down because the price increase.
But our sales adjust down to 850 units for Cola A.
And Cola B is now 700 units being sold.
See, we move people from the lower margin good to the higher margin good.
Now our new profit is going to be 8150 units of the Cola A times 35 cents.
And that gives us 297.50.
Now that extra 15 cents comes from that increase in the price of the good.
Our margin increases by the $0.15 change.
Cola B, our profit is now $385.
We had a change of $0.05 in our margin.
So we multiply the 55 margin by 700 units sold to get the $385 in profit.
So now our total is $682.50.
And we can see that we have a $182.50 profit gain simply by looking at the items pricing the lower margin item higher than the higher margin item.
Now let's move on to our compliments numerical example.
So here we're going to have our smartphone and our subscription plan.
And with these, we are selling this smartphone for $450.
We have 400 units being sold and our margin is $100 per unit.
With the subscription plan, we sell these at $50 per month and we get $20 a month in our margin and that gives us a margin of $240 per year.
Now, our original profit here, we're going to sell the phones 400 times $100 to get us $40,000.
To plan, we sell 400, multiply that by the yearly margin to get $96,000.
So our combined profit is $136,000.
Now, because these are compliments, we're going to lower the price on both of these.
And so the new smartphone price is going to be $425.
The new monthly plan is going to be $47.
And this causes our quantity demand of both of those to increase to 500 units being sold.
So our new profit becomes 500 phones times the $75 margin, and that gives us $37,500.
And recall, the reason why our margin is now 75 as opposed to 100 is because we cut into that margin by lowering price by $25.
The same logic applies to the plan.
We sell 500 plans, we have a $204 margin, which comes from the taking out $3 per month.
So 3 times 12 gives us 36.
So take the $240 margin that we had, subtract out the now $36 that we lose, and that's where the 204 comes from.
So that plan nets us 102,000 per year.
Combined profit is $139,500.
And we can see that the profit gain is going to be $3,500.
So what we see is lowering prices on both complement products, increased overall adoption and lifted profits.
This shows how coordinated price cuts across complements can grow the entire bundle.
Now, these numerical examples here help quantify what cross price elasticity describes.
Substitutes move in opposite directions.
Complements move together.
But with smart pricing across your product line, you can actively shape those outcomes to your advantage.
Now, this is an exercise for you.
Calculate what the cross price elasticity is for the substitute goods and the complement goods that we just did.
Now, I'm going to move on to our mergers, acquisitions and product strategy.
Sometimes the substitute or complement isn't one of your own products.
Sometimes it's someone else's.
And that's where acquisitions come in.
Facebook buying Instagram, well, that's a substitute.
Instagram was competing for attention.
Facebook bought it to neutralize the threat and integrate its value.
Disney buying Pixar and Marvel, well, those are compliments.
These IPs fit perfectly into Disney's flywheel movies, merchandising parks and streaming.
So by owning the compliments, Disney increased the value of its entire ecosystem.
And now let's look at some final tips here.
Managing our portfolio product means asking, how does pricing one product affect everything else that I sell?
So here are some quick tips.
Don't optimize products in isolation.
Use bundling or platform pricing when possible.
Watch for customer overlap across product lines.
And then lastly, think lifetime value, not just per unit profit.
So strategic pricing here isn't just about setting our numbers.
It's about playing offense and defense in our product ecosystem.
When we own the substitutes and complements, we control the chessboard.
So we need to make our moves wisely.
That's it.  Hope you've enjoyed it.